se alistan las maletas o rumbo a américa
latina' tanto el turismo exterior como
el turismo interno están dando sólidas
señales de recuperación el pib y
turístico regional creció un 48 2% con
respecto a 2021 y el aumento del tráfico
de pasajeros aumentó considerablemente
en la región la república dominicana ha
sido señalado como el país número uno en
la recuperación del sector en junio la
isla recibió más turistas que en toda su
historia el principal consumidor es eeuu
las reservas hechas desde el país hacia
la república dominicana méxico jamaica y
puerto rico están en aumento en
comparación con las cifras de antes de
la pandemia vemos que por ejemplo a eeuu
con su con su valorización del dólar le
conviene salir a latinoamerica porque en
nuestros países hoy con esos dólares con
los que llegan pueden hacer más cosas
pero otros países de américa latina no
lo tienen tan fácil por ejemplo perú y
chile están lejos de alcanzar los
números de visitantes de 2010 en
argentina las restricciones de uso de
dólares en el exterior hicieron florecer
el turismo interno con más nacionales
bajando adentro del país pero la alta
inflación podría repercutir pse en el
consumo de las clases medias que habrá
un sector del turismo interno que
nosotros si no ha cerrado números a lo
mejor puede llegar a hacer un análisis
de
recortes nosotros entendemos que no va a
haber mucha caída o no va a haber algo
que realmente impacte es una baja que
pueda ser analizada pero claramente no
no es mejor escenario después de la peor
crisis de turismo mundial y a pesar de
los desafíos actuales américa latina
está saliendo adelante